the host of that nfl red zone is about
to commemorate his 200th such episode
and he is my colleague from nfl network
in the nfl media group scott hanson back
here in the rich housing show how are
you scott
rich good to see you good to hear your
voice miss you man i miss you in person
well you know what i'm i'm in studio and
tell deltoofo i said hi when he got
what's up man yeah you know because hey
scott you're in you're you know i'm i'm
in the nfl
uh gameday morning studio and you are
in the red zone studio hermetically
sealed
um right around uh
right around 12 59 p.m
eastern time but out here or just shy of
10 a.m on the west coast
hermetically sealed and you're you're
not allowed to leave right you're not
allowed to leave the room
by the way hermetically sealed before it
was fashionable in a global pandemic for
everything to be hermetically sealed
i'll say
uh yeah you coined the phrase i believe
that that they lock hanson
in the studio and slide meals under the
door
uh every once in a while which is only
partly true they do lock the doors but i
don't need anything for that entire
seven hours no come on
scott scott come you do come on not even
not even uh not even some uh
some almonds not even a handful of
almonds not even i tried
i tried to have a sandwich one time and
i had a hunk of
turkey on wheat in my mouth when they're
like uh
you know dez bryant just caught a
touchdown from tony romo
and i had to call that and i i'm like
nope i
like you my microphone can be hot
at any given second right and invariably
it will
be at the most inopportune seconds so i
tried to go to a banana
okay a caged monkey i went to a banana i
figured quick to chew swallow it right
yep yep
and and that banana they bring it in and
it sits there it sits there it ripens it
ripens
it does your fruit ripens okay
all right yeah and it's a good
consistency rich you know you make
sacrifices we all make sacrifice
scott hansen here on the rich eisen show
well part of the reason why you're so
well-suited for the gig
scott um is you your your attention to
detail and your
your memory and your ability to just
draw upon what you've seen and what you
just heard
um not just from moment to moment but
from game to game week to week is is
is tremendous you got a moment for me
over the last 200 episodes of
when it all came down you were quad
boxing or six boxing or whatever
and and and all holy heck was breaking
loose
in the nfl do you remember anything over
the last several years
just like i got one for you okay i got
one for you so we came on the air in
2009.
there you go and and and there were two
arguably two seminal moments in
nfl media history and that is when you
good sir
came on the first ever episode of total
access and said i believe
you have not died and gone to football
heaven or something along that line
right yep and then the first time i came
on nfl red zone to announce
welcome to the first moments of the
channel that we hope
changes the way you watch football
forever
and it seemed like bombast at the time
hyperbole but fans
every week tell me that that's been the
case well one of the moments when we saw
the light
when it was our 2001 a space odyssey
moment
it's full of stars it was week
six 2012
and we had a triple box on yes it was
during the witching hour right the
fourth quarter of the early window of
games
and in the triple box at the bottom of
the screen was a rookie quarterback by
the name of robert griffin iii
breaking away the skins then skins had
had uh had a lead and they were trying
to ice the clock
and they needed a first down and instead
rg3 broke away for a 76 yard touchdown
run
at fedex field the crowd losing their
mind right they hadn't had a franchise
quarterback since
since steisman right so they thought oh
we got our guy we win this game
this is the everything was wonderful
four seconds later
in the upper right of the triple box a
rookie quarterback by the name of
russell wilson
threw a 50 some yard touchdown pass with
about 60 seconds left to go
to sydney rice for a game-winning
touchdown
to beat tom brady head to head right
this rookie third round draft pick
quarterback
five seconds later in the upper left
hand corner
of the triple box the arizona cardinals
with a
go blue university of michigan former
kicker by the name of jay
feeling yes lined up a game-winning
field goal
and at the end of regulation and he
stoicked it off the
left upright i believe it was and they
went to overtime
but it was bang bang bang in a triple
box and we were like
oh my gosh that just happened i think we
covered it pretty well
you can float that's floating around
there on social media on youtube and
whatnot if anyone wants to relive that
but
that was maybe one of the greatest
moments we've had where it was just like
wow
you saw all those things and you would
have you would have seen none of them or
just
one of them if you were just watching
traditional broadcasts i love it scott
hanson here on the rick johnson show
i'm i'm not mistaken chris was that the
you mad bro
when richard sherman went up to brady
after the game when
you're right when because that game i
remember when when
seattle and russell wilson beat
brady in the patriots it was like okay
i think the seahawks are something to
start paying attention to that the
legion of boom and russell and the
seahawks that have been in
dire need of an identity outside
of pete carroll and their burgeoning
running game with
obviously beastquake needing the
quarterback to add to all of that
that was a big moment for the seahawks
in their whole pete carroll
russell wilson legion of boom run scott
that was a big moment 2012 if chris
is googling it there just to confirm i
believe it was the umad bro game
and uh and yeah the rest was history
well if you go through that triple box
right there
in reverse order you know j feely had a
very very fine nfl career and missed
that kick but it was just it was a game
changing moment that we caught rg3 was
the moment we
thought we have seen the next great
franchise quarterback because i think it
was a week or two
after he had the the huge touchdown pass
in the superdome to beat the saints
and remember when he ended up on his
butt they knocked him back on his butt
he was sitting
on his keister holding up his arms and
touchdown uh and there were the classic
images and
with the dual threat capability that he
had in his young career
we thought wow washington finally has
their franchise quarterback
and then russell wilson to beat tom
brady was just like what
how what right and and it did it did
make us
stand up and take notice and and we've
caught all the moments since you know i
mean
you talk about just i mean heck the hell
the hail murray right
unless you had that local broadcast
right you you were not gonna see the
hail murray and
the the the laterals two years ago the
laterals for the miami dolphins with
gronk missing the tackle
inside the five yard line the miami
miracle
right the the buffalo bills ending their
playoff
drought the longest was the longest
active drought in the nfl 20 years of no
playoffs right
they had to beat the dolphins they
remember they took care of business they
were down in miami
they they finished but then like three
minutes later they were in the locker
room and of course the indelible image
of them
celebrating they had to have the ravens
lose to the bengals of all teams and the
bengals hit the game-winning touchdown
with a minute left
on nfl red zone we bounced you back and
forth between those two moments right
and then uh
and then all of western new york filled
up the coffers of andy dalton's
charities
you know you know it's just these are
just great moments to
to go back and forth with scott hanson
here on the rich eisen show so how
how how does everybody if you will
celebrate the 200th broadcast
i mean what do you what do you do well
what do you got what do you got planned
uh we're going to have a flashback or
two
there's always the flashback okay and i
had to look it up now you are mr
pop culture right anyone at nfl media i
mean everyone who watches the rich
eisenhower he knows this but right
everyone at nfl media if there's a pop
culture question if somebody stumped on
trivia you hit up eisen
sure and and he can usually dig it out
let's play a little you got time for a
little game here scott
i'm always up for this and just so
everyone else is aware
that in those years we actually
reminisced about this earlier in the
week we talked about it jim
we talked about it uh earlier this week
that
the combine always falls on the weekend
of the academy awards
and we talked about this because when
dick for meal the subject of vermeel
came up and how he cried the night that
uh scorsese won his uh finally won his
oscar for the departed
but the person who always if there was
ever a tie
in the ensuing years we had uh uh dozens
of
uh nfl network staffers take part in a
in an oscar pool
the individual who we always turn to for
the tie break question
scott hanson so this is this is a role
with which you're quite familiar scott
what you're about to play right here
i i didn't even think about that when i
was devising what i'm about to ask you
right now but yeah
i've been i've been accused or credited
with being part game show host so
you know i i i i is a title i embrace
scottish and you should there's nothing
wrong with being accused of being that
it's good living no doubt what's on your
mind so what do you got for me
all right here we go 200 episodes of nfl
red zone that's right this sunday is
episode 200. rank
these sitcoms from
most episodes to least episodes okay
homelessness
hold on a second let me let me get a pen
here all right just three of them
please tell me one of them is mash do
you give me mash
okay nope nope all right let's get a
little more modern
seinfeld yep the office
the united states office yes 30 rock
okay i will go uh in terms of episodes
i will go um so it's got to be most
to least episodes right yeah i just
looked it up because i'm like well how
long did
you know certain sitcoms run did they
have 200 episodes like where you know
were they around there and these three
all are in the realm okay 200 episodes
but rank them just rank them most to
least first
first of all scott excellent uh
braintease right here thank you and then
two
uh on brand as well right here on nbc
sports on peacock we greatly appreciate
you choosing these three shows as your
choice
well done scott uh right on brand we
appreciate that
i'm gonna go um chris you want to take
part in this as well
sure sure i i'm i i'll give mine you
give yours and we'll see who's right
okay
i'm gonna go number one office number
two thirty rock and
i'm gonna go seinfeld three chris what
do you got uh i
i agree with office first i'm gonna go
seinfeld second thirty rock third what
do you got
scott brockman
he nailed it nailed it i just i kind of
put seinfeld third because i thought
you were throwing that in there to throw
me off the scent but you're
actually straight on i was actually just
watching 30 rock over the weekend it's
so good
by the way which you can see right here
favorite of all those three 30 rock is
is is my absolute favorite i can
re-watch it so get here's the episodes
so again nfl red zone 200 the office
yes 201. ah they just got you one they
just got you scott
they just got well just wait just wait
till week 15. yeah you'll get them don't
worry it's okay
seinfeld second 180
180 and that's including the like the
two hour
special at the end you know all that
stuff and then 30 rock
138 they packed a lot of humor into that
138
i guess and just to bring this all full
circle one of our favorite moments uh
in the history of our old podcast uh was
a 30 rock uh producer writer
um telling us the story of how rg3 after
he got
um he got drafted um second overall in
radio city music hall strolled down the
street
and uh watched the live taping of 30
rock that was going on that night
airing on nbc uh and kim kardashian came
over to this writer producer to ask if
rg3 was single
so that brings us all full circle
on your rg3 story and my rg3 story
and 30 rock and uh red zone is the uh
is the glue is the connective tissue who
knew that's a fact
that's a fact bringing millions together
for 12 years and it was truly one of the
most
uh uh one of the largest pieces of
attention uh and publicity our
rich eyes and podcast ever got and we
had
we were we we had a lot of people on
that we did but
good old jack burditt came on die hard
uh browns fan
fan and he calls me up the next day he
goes uh i i i think i shouldn't have
told you this
hey scott it's a major achievement
people got to comb your show
people got to comb your show for the the
sound bite the the
the the news drop you guys are you know
i got five screens on my media wall in
my house now
right obviously i watch nine tvs for a
living but i got five screens on my
media wall
and and i i always dip into the rich
eisen show when when there's
you know guests scott you'd probably
tell that to rome when you're gonna be
on his show too come on scott
i i gotta go i got roman five minutes
no i'm playing i'm playing rich you know
i love you bro
you're the original nfl network and i
came in about a year and a half after
you did and
here we are after all these years hey
man and uh congrats it's an incredible
milestone
it's remarkable that your attention span
is not been totally destroyed because
you're constantly watching 15 screens
you do get some sleep right you do you
at least have the blue screen glasses if
scott you ever get i mean you must uh
your
your brain must be on fire looking at
all these screens all the time
the night before saturday night i am so
wired i know surprising right that i get
wired right
but uh i am so wired on saturday night i
can only sleep for about
three or four hours i'm saying and and
then you know i wake up and game day
mornings first thing that's on obviously
but then sunday night i am dead to the
world
i i go away and the last thing you
watched on one screen was 30 rock
basically that's it that's the last
thing you watched on one single screen i
i've got that loaded up on my tablet
to go for old episodes gets me through
an elliptical training session or
whatever in the gym
scott hanson uh nfl zone red host with
an
on-brand constant mentioning of nbc
shows that can be streamed right here on
peacock
well done scott thank you appreciate the
call until grant tinker i said hi there
you go wow look at that's dropping us
white shadow he's gonna he's going white
shadow he's going out the door that's
scott hanson thanks the call brother
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here